During dispatch, we haven't consider a situation when more than one instruction
is ready to execute. So let's do that. So here's a situation where we have
a similar broadcast to the previous case where we have reorganization station 1
is broadcasting these out of minus 0.29. So we're still going to
free a reservation station 1 as before. We will still going to capture all of
the results that hasn't changed. So here we're going to match minus 0.29.
This doesn't need to match anything. Here because we already have a value.
Here we're going to also latch zero point twenty nine, and here we're going to
do the same thing. But now we have a situation where for the multiplication and
divide unit it's pretty clear that this the instruction that gets to execute. So
this is easy. But here, we have to choose between one of these two.
Because assuming that the adder can only handle one instruction per cycle.
We need to pick one of these. And, now we have to figure out which one.
So there needs to be some logic that's going to pick one of these instructions,
because both of them cannot go. Now we need to figure out, you know, are there
any good rules about which one should go first? So our question is basically,
should we dispatch RS1 or RS2? Well, ideally we will dispatch that instruction
that allows us to kind of get to future instructions as early as possible. So
basically we would choose the instruction that leads to the highest performance.
Unfortunately that requires knowledge of the future.
And this is something that hardware is pretty bad at doing.
Because we only can really look here at these instructions here.
And maybe the next couple of instructions in the instruction queue.
While in reality the situation might change, for
example this instruction. Might have a lot of dependent instructions later on,
and this one might have a few. But we don't know that until we see those a lot
of instructions later on. So, it's very difficult to decide that based on kind
of perfect knowledge of the future. So, how do we choose these instructions?
Well, there are some heuristics. We can not really do a perfect job of it, but
we can make some reasonably good guesses. One choice that usually makes a lot of
sense is oldest first. So pretty much whichever, whichever of these instructions
has been sitting here longer will be allowed to go first. Why? Well because for
an older instruction all other things being equal, it's more likely that more
instructions are by now waiting for it. Simply you know, if an instruction is
older. By now you could have seen more instructions that will use it's values.
And also this allows us to kind of, you know, mark of some instructions as done.
So basically oldest first is a typical heuristic that gets done this way.
Another one that could be used is something like most dependencies first where
we will check. How many other instructions need the value from each one of
these. And then use the one, I mean, you know, dispatch the one that will,
that will can free up more, the most of the other instructions. But
this one would be very, this, how would I say, would be difficult to implement.
Because we have to actually like search a lot of stuff,
which is going to be very power hungry and so on. So typically,
if we do anything, we will just do the oldest first. Another choice would be,
to just randomly select the instruction. Like for example, whichever is
comes first in order of preservation stations or something like that. So
something that has nothing to do with their age in the preservation station, or
whoever has most dependencies. This strategy also works because, note that.
If we don't send the oldest first, we will eventually run out of things to do.
Because all of the things will depend on the oldest instruction,
at which point it will rot. So basically, it's not a problem regarding
correctness if we choose something other than oldest first or
dependence first. It's just an issue of kind of what works reasonably well. So
typically, all this first does help somewhat with like releasing instructions.
>From here, while, you know, random is okay as far as just, you know,
correctness is concerned. So pretty much anyone of these three would work.
It's just a matter of, you know, which one would lead to the best performance.
And we kind of choose an oldest first as a kind of compromise between,
what we have to look at. And you know what gives us good performance. So
would random give us kind of the worse performance, and
this would give us the best performance. But this is kind of easy to do so
we kind of compromise between the two.